what's up guys how you doing let's go
we're in quarantine so you know what
that means we're coming out with a new
experiment that's right lunch money show
we're going to everyday break down the
top topics going on I don't really care
about the news a little bit more
entertainment but the whole idea is that
while Wall Street's getting rich the
rest of us are just trying to get our
lunch money right so every day around
noon ish Y ish because we don't have our
[ __ ] together sometimes it'll come out a
little before noon a little after noon
maybe right at noon or maybe at 5:00
o'clock
who knows but I'll come to you every day
we'll talk about the top topics
sometimes it'll be just me other times
I'll have a co-host that calls in but
either way we're gonna cover the top
topics we're gonna have a little bit of
fun we're gonna try to educate some
folks while not being too ridiculous so
today's first show we're gonna try this
out maybe it works maybe it doesn't
if it breaks who cares but we're gonna
give it a try so let's jump into the
topics the first is federal Jets we've
got dr. Donny Trump on Twitter keeps
tweeting all about his TV ratings saying
hey I've got the best TV ratings they're
comparable with the Bachelorette finale
Monday Night Football
etc of course everyone is just laying in
on I'm saying what do you care about
your TV ratings but at the same time
you've got all of these Jets that are
flying to Shanghai so the US
government's actually sending Jets to
pick up 80 tons of medical equipment and
personal protective equipment in
Shanghai and bringing it back to the US
the first one happened this weekend flew
into New York City
we've got other flights going into
Chicago and Ohio over the next couple of
days and then they'll kind of move out
to other cities from there
but it's pretty funny to see kind of the
public persona and the tweeting and the
TV ratings and all this stuff at the
same time we got federal jets why they
call federal jets I don't know just
selling a cool name
so I got my notes here because that's
what smart people do they got notes what
we're picking up in the plains is
130,000 n95 masks 1.8 million face masks
10 million gloves and thousands of
thermometers obviously this stuff is
super needed already we've seen JB
Pritzker the governor of Illinois who's
come out and said hey you sent me all
these
but they're the wrong kind and so you
gotta remember that there's just a bunch
of logistical stuff that's going on
right now and this stuff's hard I'm
removing 80 tons of medical equipment
from Shanghai to the US on short notice
in chartered planes etc and so that's
just the world we live in today right is
literally we're having to send planes to
another country to pick stuff up when we
get out of this virus thing I think
you're gonna see a lot of those supply
chains come back onshore the United
States go deeper kind of protect
ourselves from being in a situation
where we rely on other people in order
to get a lot of this personal protective
equipment so that then leads me to if
that's the healthcare crisis what's
going on in the economic market well Jim
Cramer on television yesterday said hey
if you're a short seller you're betting
against science well newsflash Jim no
you're not his whole argument is that
there's gonna be some sort of vaccine or
some sort of cure for coronavirus has
eventually figured out that's probably
true I don't doubt that but at the same
time look I'm sitting here in my kitchen
I got a plan over my shoulder I got an
instant pot that polenta loves I got a
refrigerator I'm not at work I'm in my
kitchen if I'm in my kitchen and
everyone else is in their kitchen and in
their living room and in their bedroom
that means we're all sitting arrested at
home the economy is not going to recover
why everyone's sitting at home we're
only gonna get our recovery in the
economy when people go back to work when
American businesses turn back on when
the Greece to the flywheel starts going
that's how we get the economy to recover
it's not about the science it's not
about a cure it's not about a vaccine
that stuff will help but the only
solution to the economy is to get people
back to work and so Jim love you man but
short cells aren't betting get science
they're just checking reality there's
telling everyone and telling the market
hey a lot of these companies even though
their stock prices have fallen 30 40 50
60 70 percent they're still overvalued
go look at all the hospitality companies
the travel companies etc revenue
literally went right off a cliff it's
gone and maybe it'll come back maybe it
won't but we don't know that stuff yet
and so we need those short sales in
order to kind of do true price discovery
in the marketplace and understand what
exactly is the value that exists there
today I don't think it's them betting
against science I think it's actually
them betting on reality
and betting on the fact that the
economy's not gonna recover as long as
you mean everyone else is sitting at
home looking at our computers and zoom
in with our family rather than being
able to go out spend money and create
economic activity so that then leads us
to when the hell are we gonna get out of
quarantine we're all sitting here super
bored everyone's just watching stupid
videos on Instagram or on Twitter or a
Centon means to each other downloading
the latest app trying to watch Netflix
shout out Tiger king the dudes a legend
but when are we gonna get out of this
thing and there's two pieces to this
that are gonna be really important right
one is is social distance II working are
we able to flatten the curve can we get
people back into society without the
spread of the virus that seems to be
going well but it just takes time right
there's people who are saying that it
could end as early as the end of April
but then the state of Virginia yesterday
said hey if you're staying at home
you're gonna have to be there till June
10th June 10th is really really far away
it's like 70 plus days away and so
there's a lot of people who are saying
whoa I didn't expect 70 days into
quarantine
but that's what we're facing right now
the second body of work is can we get a
cure can we get some sort of vaccine on
the Cure side you see the
hydroxychloroquine sound like a
scientist when I say that that seems to
be progressing nicely and it looks like
that could be a solution but again it'll
take a little bit of time until we know
for sure the big thing is Johnson &
Johnson starting this September kind of
in q3 to actually inject humans with a
vaccine or a potential vaccine now I
have no clue I'm actually not a
scientist on whether it'll work or not
but what I do know is once they start
injecting people it will take 10 to 12
months in general until we know whether
it works or not why do they have to wait
so long well we got to make sure that
whatever we're injecting in people
doesn't kill them obviously now what I
want to know is who's the first person
who says you know what hit me up with a
shot how is this gonna work right do
they go out on Craigslist and put out an
ad and say hey and then we're looking
for 500 bucks
do they have kind of a whole group of
people that are already volunteers and
then they just select somebody do they
do one person do they do a hundred
people I don't know all I know is that
they're gonna start injecting people
with something they think could be a
vaccine but you know going into it if
you're getting injected you're the
guinea pig you're the test dummy right
you don't know are you gonna die or are
you gonna survive and I'm
but they make you sign a bunch of forms
and say you understand the risk you're
taking but still I want to know who
those people are and also what's what
are they being compensated for right how
do they actually get paid or what are
they getting in exchange for being the
person who takes the injection no clue
but just seems like kind of a weird
situation that's going on there
so that'll start in q3 this year but
still gonna take on twelve to fourteen
months in order to get that vaccine
efficacy figured out so while all of
this is happening we've got federal jets
flying around picking up PPE so that
nurses aren't wearing trash bags in
hospitals we've got short sellers and
equity buyers going long and short and
create an almost volatility in the
markets and then we've got healthcare
companies trying to figure out cures and
vaccines Senate says you know what we
just passed the stimulus bill two
trillion dollars that was a big body of
work we've worked really really hard
this year we're gonna take a vacation
that's right normally the Senate recess
was scheduled from April 6 to the 17th
where they go home they go home they
just go on vacation right it's a recess
it's kind of like in school you get a
break from classwork now you go to
recess well that's what the Senate is
supposed to do from April 6 to the 17th
but instead they decided we work really
hard this year let's actually extend the
amount of time that we have so they went
on recess this week it'll extend to
April 20th so literally people are
getting paid hundreds of thousands of
dollars and supposed to be representing
us they're going on vacation I don't
know go back to Washington do some
voting do some negotiating do some
politicking do whatever you guys do on a
daily basis but don't go on vacation it
in the time where we need the most
leadership we have people leaving at a
time where you think that people are
actually looking for their leaders their
elected representatives to say hey
everything's gonna be ok it's gonna do
what we needed to do meaning the
government the health care system the
economy etc but all of a sudden they're
going home I just don't think that
that's right of course they're gonna
make the argument oh well there's some
people who got sick and we all need to
leave so that we don't you know violate
the quarantine we're gonna subject
ourselves the same that everyone else is
yeah maybe there's an argument there but
I think that what's more important is
you're an elected representative
you're supposed to be voting politicking
negotiating doing deals wheeling do baby
whatever you got to do get the work done
don't just go home because it's
unlike the two trillion-dollar stimulus
package is going to be enough we're
probably gonna need more help and if
you're on vacation it's really hard for
you to once they plugged in - what's
going on - in case there's an emergency
and three hello this hole is is an
entire confidence team people are
looking and saying is it gonna be okay
and what does that tell us if all of a
sudden our elected representatives go on
vacation I don't know not really the
smartest thing in my opinion so that
leads to the last thing the Federal
Reserve all this money is being created
they're already buying all kinds of
credit products they're doing everything
from Treasuries to mortgage-backed
securities corporate debt etc now
there's talk that they actually may be
able to buy equities that's right
imagine if the Federal Reserve could now
start to buy equities in the market
we're seeing a little bit of this now
with some of the payoffs around the
airline's people are being told hey if
you take the bailout money we're gonna
have an equity stake in your business
that's kind of a special situation if
you will but we're talking about in the
equity side is the Federal Reserve
literally having a pool of capital where
they're buying equities it's unclear if
they would be doing like index type
stuff with the SMP or if they'd be
actually picking individual stocks all I
keep saying to myself is imagine Jerome
Powell sitting at the Federal Reserve
taking off his Federal Reserve hat
putting on his Gerry stock picker hat
and saying you know what I think Dunkin
Donuts is going up today and I think
that Spirit Airlines is going down I
don't think that's what they're gonna do
but you can just imagine the slippery
slippery slope we get into if all of a
sudden you get people who are government
elected officials or working at the
Treasury the Federal Reserve etc and
they start trying to pick stocks or or
do anything they're really really bad
slippery slope and so my hope is that
the Federal Reserve is actually gonna
steer clear of buying equities stick
with the products that they currently
buy I hope that we can turn this around
get the American economy turn back on it
just seems like it's only gonna get
worse before it gets better and so keep
an eye out for not only more stimulus
but also what are they gonna be able to
buy are they gonna get an expansion of
those assets that they can purchase they
would need congressional approval to do
it but weirder things have happened
we've literally seen in oh wait no nine
hundreds of billions of dollars in
stimulus now we're talking trillions
previously we saw all sorts of credit
products
why wouldn't we do equities today I
think that's part of the conversation so
remember every single day around noon
we'll be coming to you with lunch money
while Wall Street trying to get rich the
rest of us trying to get our lunch money
right I can't promise you that we're
gonna do this forever but I can promise
you that it's gonna be funded
entertaining while we do it now
here's the whole key hold me accountable
at noon every day
noon ish y ish because we don't have our
[ __ ] together but before noon afternoon
right at noon or at 5:00 o'clock every
day we're gonna come to you
we're gonna bring you the news send us
tweets subscribe do all the stuff that
I'm supposed to say that I forgot
already that's not in my notes and I'll
talk to you guys tomorrow